uh third year of minor three plus two
but he has nice rating so let's play him
let's give him a chance
it's three plus two but i mean okay he's
three thousands rated
so he hopes to keep his
high rating points
okay let's take queen d3
it used to be my favorite line against
the pulsar
just bishop f4 so it's now transposes
into the rouser
there is
basically the same
now he's thinking why did he challenge
me for a rated game yeah he had such a
nice
rating of 3001.
there is uh by the way there is uh
a challenge on uh
uh i think a friendly channel of levitt
of chess
very grandmaster alexander shimanov
actually is trying to break
three thousands on a new account
actually i guess uh on the old account
he didn't do that
so far but you know and he
is coming relatively close to the point
but
yeah he is just struggling here so there
is
it will be one more show for him to to
hit it
and i guess it was uh first of all it
was designed
as a speed run like you know like he
carried us like from zero to
three thousands but now it's already
like
i guess uh the drama is already
for half a year or or something
so yeah it it takes really a while from
him
yeah h4 just to prepare queen g3
uh do you go queen g3 anyway yeah i
think so
maybe after bishop seven and i'm winning
his queen maybe not
no probably not
what sometimes he's
ready to give me this check on h6 but
besides this i don't see the point
i could also go king b1
will be just fine
queen before i guess just a3
mcqueen is 70k returned
and he still uh have some troubles with
the
development development so let's give
her a q1
and probably some topical stuff like
ed95 or bishop b5 should work
and also like d6 is too weak so yeah
that's sort of a set position for black
indeed
yeah like takes takes only six or
something
we retreat
so he probably should try castle here
and if
give up an exchange rate i'm not even
sure i gotta i gotta take it
it's probably unnecessary for me
i guess i'll just go e5 i like my bishop
more than uh
his knight then his rook sorry
so i take
and well let's probably bring the rook
by for frank to g4
so he wants to he wants to keep the rook
alive okay now it's time
now it's time to you know take some
material benefits
yeah not the most possible game for my
opponent i guess
this is
this happens quite often
in chess
what do i do let me just go f4 and g3
okay maybe i mean it's
it's not the best way to play indeed but
it still makes some sense just to open
up files
i guess 94
green takes
f3 why is that okay that i'll just take
so let's do rook f1
this lets me grenade as well but
okay i don't think i should uh seek for
some
super brilliant move here just what's
the most natural is probably the best
yeah thanks for the game and for some
points
very kind of here